hi my name is kay ganda the last ten
years I was concerned about the neural
code and decoding investigating the
neural code at the recordings from rat
visual cortex and today I will talk
about ways to analyze the data that I
got and ways to decode information
that's in there with Mathematica and I
hope you enjoy it most interesting
application possible it's about cracking
the neural code and why is it
interesting at all well although it
might be obvious let me scales up a bit
let me start with a quote from good old
Donald Hebb Canadian psychologist who
said and back in 1949 modern psychology
takes completely for granted that
behavior neural function are perfectly
correlated that one is completely caused
by the other there is no separate soul
or life for us to stick a finger to the
brain now and then and make neural cells
to what they would not otherwise one
cannot logically be determinist in
physics and chemistry and biology and a
mystic in psychology if one is to be
consistent there's no room here for
mysterious agent that is define it's not
physical and yet has physical effects
mind can only be regarded for scientific
purposes as the activity of the brain
and this should be mr. enough for anyone
so it's clear that both behavior mind
cognition and neural activity in the
brain is far from being random so there
must be some relationship between the
two which we could call a code so in
principle I code can be defined in
general by relation between who sets of
symbols which is the code input set
thats related through a correlation
function to a code word set input status
all the all the symbols of the
correlation function accepts as an input
and the court would set us all the as
all the symbols that the correlation
function can generate applied
neurocognitive code this would be the
neuronal symbols that bring about in
whatever way cognitive functions and the
neural code would be your own symbols
that somehow translate into
other neuronal symbols so on the level
of brain activity and this is what we
are after what we are looking for and if
you find these symbols we can somehow
maybe rate them to completion and say
something about how the brain works now
this is essentially data-mining task
because you can record brain activity
but it'll be very beginning you don't
know what you're looking for so you have
to define what your own symbols could be
and on the level of a single neuron it's
pretty clear what this would be Sonoran
looks like this it has a soma here and
then writes with many synapse is that
get inputs from other cells and an axon
that sends the output signal of the cell
if there is one to other cells and what
you see here is the membrane potential
of an example sale over time and these
so-called spikes here these action
potentials are very brief pulses of less
than a millisecond adoration and these
are so to say the digital result of an
analog computation done by the cell the
seller combines all the input signals it
gets and every now and then it thinks
it's necessary so to say it sends out
this this big action potential pulse
down is excellent to to the recipient
cells and if record XO cellular has
depicted here with this electrode you
will see these small accessory very
brief pulse is appearing so on the level
of a single cell this this is clearly a
neuronal symbol but this is this yes or
no it's a binary signal but of course
the whole thing is much more complicated
if you go to populations of cells you
have at every instant of time you have a
number of cells firing and this might
depend on how many factors so for
example different stimuli that you have
here it's think of these this population
of cells as some cells in some sensory
area and the brain and a different
stimuli illicit activity in different
cell populations that might overlap of
course if you go to higher levels you
can also think of
stimulates being eternally generated by
some other cell populations and you have
these sequences of co active cells so
this is theoretically the level on which
we have to look for your own symbols and
your own codes so the questions would be
how independent are these cells so are
they completely independent do they
somehow rely on each other and it's
clear from a information in theoretical
standpoint that there must be some
redundancy that there must be some some
relation between the cells they cannot
be completely independent but if they
would be completely dependent again and
this would also be bad for for
information transmission so there must
be something in between then of course
the spatial organization of these these
Co active cell assemblies and the time
scales on which they the time sets that
met her and it's also clear and theory
that this is smaller the time scale so
the faster the symbols appear and our
computed the better it would be for the
performance of of the brain and animals
or humans so this is the task the data
mining tasks that I was after and it
very roughly translates into this sketch
so you have here the number of parallel
recordings so-called spike trains so we
have here these these timing of the
events that your aquatic in principle
could be anything so you can now even
start to think of other data that might
look like this in this case it's
neuronal signals and what we need to do
is to define a timescale called w here
some window of interest where we think
the neuronal symbols are n so they are
not there not much smaller maybe there
they are not much bigger so some window
depicted SW and some timing precision of
these events inside the window depicted
as tau that's the basic concept and
across the population of course as I
said so what would we need to do so we
have some original data and we look for
in a time-resolved a systematic manner
look for repeating spatial temporal
patterns on arbitrary time scales so
this is the variable that is
in the analysis and detect repeating
patterns first and the original data now
the patterns that we find no one knows
in the beginning if they are if they
appear randomly or not so if there's any
meaning of these patterns that do repeat
so we need some some baseline for this
some statistical model and the problem
is that the single spike train or the
intervals between events in a single
spike train do not have any distribution
that would be known so you can
approximate this with a gamma
distribution for example but it's not
precisely a gamma distribution so
there's no analytical way to solve this
so what we need to do is to construct
surrogate data from the original data by
destroying only this feature in this in
this orbit data that we want to test for
and there are different ways to do this
for example here in a one could you tell
the timing of every single event
independently but in this way you
destroy the auto structure of each train
and it's unclear what this does to the
to the statistics so this is maybe not a
good idea although it's used to that a
bit more conservative way would be to
simply keep the intervals in one train
as they are and to shift the whole hold
the timing of the whole train a little
bit against each other so you destroy
the cross structure of the train but
keep the oil to structure this is a
viable way to do it and going a bit
further I developed the variant of this
by also swapping intervals that are
small enough below some time scale in
these trains to make them even more
distinct from each other then we repeat
the whole analysis on on each of these
surrogate data sets and then we count
the occurrences of every individual
pattern that we found in the original
data and in the saga data sets and
compare them on an individual level to
the counts of that pattern in the other
data sets do very simple non-traumatic
statistical tests on it may be making a
binomial test or whatever you like it
doesn't matter on that level and discard
all the patterns that are not
significant statistical way on the
individual level and then
the same thing on a second level and
count the overall occurrences of the
patterns that are statistically
significant between and compare this
number between the original data and the
surrogate data it is a very important
segment of a test and if the data passes
this test then we know there is some
structure on the original data as
compared to the surrogate data it is
non-random and then we can have a closer
look at the results so this is maybe the
most important slide of the talk and
this is how it's done these are real
data as an example and we have here time
scale w times square tau and we with a
sliding window we go through all the
data and collect all the patterns that
are in there and represent them with a
wouldn't vector that the most the
easiest way to do it is to at tau equal
w and only have the rank of the events
in the vector in this case it's unit
number three fired first then unit
number two the unit number four and you
have this vector of three to four this
would be the pattern now we run into a
severe problem can anyone imagine what
the problem might be on this step well
there might be larger patterns
consisting of let's say 20 events and
there's there's actually a sub pattern
of it maybe consisting of five events
that is significant it does repeat we
wouldn't see it if we keep it as a as a
larger pattern and process this larger
pattern so we would need to somehow
separate the events in this larger
pattern and make smaller ones of them
but now now we run into a combinatorial
explosion so if we have 20 events we can
combine more than a million ways this
means that out of one pattern we make a
million ones and we need to test each of
them and and this is simply you cannot
handle it so it takes too much time and
too much memory in the computer to do it
so I can help with a little trick it's a
little bit cheating but I introduced
another time scale called T and computer
correlations of the of the single units
per time period t and and then I
separated the patterns according to that
to that thresholded metrics here and for
example from this first vector here 3124
we get rid of unit number one because it
doesn't belong to the others and then we
we end up with three to four again so
this helps a lot and I show you
afterwards this actually has a positive
effect on the on the result this is how
the simulated data look like that are
used for for validating the method i
will show you later a quick
demonstration of this the day are
assimilated according to 30 units and 50
seconds time with on average like a few
hundred events per unit with repeating
patterns like these so we have six
different patterns consisting of five
units that occur within five minutes
second windows these are the details
they don't matter so it's simulated them
which is conveniently done in
Mathematica with gamma processes with
certain parameters and these are results
of the testing the method with the
simulated data so you see here that on
the second level statistics the false
positive rate is below five percent as
it should be so here on the right row we
have this shuffling method as I showed
you before and see if you remember this
orchid 80 generating method is called
shuffling and devotes and it's slightly
better than the others if you compare so
we have here the false positive rate
here the detection rate because the
patterns are masked mostly by events
that occur within the same time window
there are of course there are remains
some remaining difficulties in detecting
them so the check return rate is not a
hundred percent but it might be good
enough and it's slightly better here on
the right row and this is the test power
and four different bromley combinations
you see that you get close to eighty
percent
if the pattern excess and the river is
about between fifteen and twenty percent
so it's a conservative test test power
is not brilliant but I think good enough
and the important bit is that the false
positives are low enough so it can be
applied and I did this to to the
recording so this is the recording setup
that I built in previous years and at
the Max Planck Institute for brain
research in Frankfurt there were briefly
is our recorded from brain slices from
reputable cortex with this so-called you
top rope these are silicon needles
electrodes essentially with platen 80
tips with an electric distance of five
microns and you can stick them into
until the tissue and record the activity
of many single cells and this how the
data looks like so this is it how a
spike actually looks like so these are
two milliseconds and on each channel you
record actually more than one cells or
with a method called spike sorting you
can separate these these cases if you
wish of events and then you get this
sort of data so any sort of data that
looks like this so you have parallel
trains time series of events any data
that looks like this can be analyzed
with this method and now the analysis
goes like having a sliding window of a
duration w sliding them over the data
collecting the pattern separating them
according to the cross relations on time
security and compare them to the
surrogate data see what i see what we
get sorry the color code is just if it's
red it means that the resolution is too
bad that you can see all the black ones
so it's many many you mean heat up
these are the results so if a used 10
different time windows w from 5 to 50
milliseconds and this is the data mining
thing so I didn't know what time scale
might be important so I use different
ones and here is a very rough analysis
of the excess of Queensland spikes in
this time window and you already see
that when you compare the Virgin later
with a surrogate data that within time
windows of 5 milliseconds and still in
10 milliseconds you get much more events
concentrated in these time windows and
the original data remember that the
original data only differ in the timing
of events so the number of events is the
same the surrogate data there's a first
indication is there something going on
on these short timescales here this is
the number of individual patterns that
are significant on the individual level
comparing originated on server data and
you see that it is significant up to
about 30 milliseconds and then not
anymore and here is an as an example of
that so if you have a time window of 5
milliseconds this is the distribution
that you get off of counts of stuff
significant patterns in the surrogate
data and the arrow depicts the original
result if you go to 35 milliseconds in
the same data you see that you get
essentially a random result with this
time window so this was an indication
that the symbols that we're looking for
do not appear on larger time scales and
maybe 10 milliseconds or so and having a
closer look at the patterns that are
significant please first concentrate on
the left side we have again 10 graphs
showing the results for 5 10 15 and so
on up to 50 millisecond windows and what
you see is the distribution of pattern
durations and in grey you see the chance
level this is this the result from the
surrogate data and you clearly see that
there's a prominent peak between one and
two milliseconds going roughly 25 milli
second duration where the original data
clearly shows a feature and
and show feature and deviate from the
surrogate data and that's that's the
main result so the point is I didn't put
this into the there's no assumption in
analysis saying that while we're looking
for coincident events in let's say 10
milliseconds no no if we have a time
window of 50 milliseconds you get this
distribution allowing for much longer
events but you get this from an peak if
there would be no characteristic scale
of these patterns then the distribution
would be entirely flat it's not there's
a peak between one or two milliseconds
and this graph be here just as zoomed in
we have two conditions here by the way
spontaneous activity and activities that
was electrically stimulated it's
essentially the same so there is
something going on in the first five
milliseconds second thing is if you if
you look at the temporal precision of
these events you can analyze this by by
having some average time so we have a
pattern that repeats ten times and you
compute the average timing of the events
in this pattern and compare this to the
individual timings of these ten repeats
then you again get a distribution that
is extremely precise and interestingly
enough follows a power law as you can
see and see I'll come back to that later
so the conclusions this of course all
speculation but at least we have
something in our hands now the transient
or anization of a selective group of
cells may correspond to a meaningful
transition from one cognitive state to
another while previously it's separate
aspects of some seemingly meaningful
information combined to give way to
holistic experience like receiving an
object reaching a decision or becoming
aware of some thought or idea this would
apply to all those this yeah would agree
with the principle of structure
coherence from David Chalmers
philosopher and this is of course can
only be speculation but at least there's
something and so we did a maid data
mining task on the data and and we found
some what we could call symbols that
repeat so there must be some some
meaning to them and we can think about
what it might be
another interesting aspect is this power
that I was talking about so the obtained
distribution of spike time Jeter it
seems to follow a power law which has
been regarded as a signature of seven as
criticality in outs of course tempting
to suppose that under the given
conditions cortical networks have
organized into a critical state in which
the noise affecting the timing of action
potentials is tuned to a critical point
this again only speculation but it looks
promising well this explanation halls
but what mechanisms such a point might
be reached and whether spike temperature
and vivo this was done in vitro from
from brain slices also follows a power
remains to be investigative course and I
like really to stress this point and
point us out that this pattern reaction
method can of course be applied to any
other data I like for example fMRI data
just by adapting the parameters and the
temporal scales so it's it's open to any
sort of of data and if time permits I
hope so here's a quick demonstration of
so this is actually the note that are
used and you can also download it and
use it I just want to change that so
that I can handle that
initialize a notebook if the parameters
this is the it's not just a
demonstration of the simulator that I
was talking about its 52nd data set
consisting of 30 units with about 7,500
events in indem and what would you guess
how long would it take to to do the
sliding window analysis on the data long
done now this was the original data and
now we construct the circuit data as
told the notebook to do 20 survey data
sets the average spikes placement in
time was seven point oh 3 milliseconds
let me see okay now we do the same thing
in each of these 20 survey data sets 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 done now we do
the testing on each individual pattern
and the second deficit is your test get
a graph out of it let's it look hope you
can see it yeah so in light grey is the
circuit data and dark gray the original
data and you can cause clearly see as
expected because I put them in there are
long random patterns in the original
data here's a statistical test saying
that is of course significant and then
we save the results as text files come
on
and you could have a look at it let's
simply text files and you see that the
patterns that should be in there like
for example this unit 16 17 18 19 20 in
time bands 1 2 3 4 5 is there it has
been detected so this whole works and I
just want to give you a brief outlook
how we could improve this of course very
easy to do when I actually did this
already one could paralyze the time
concealing steps in the computation with
the parallel commands like parallel map
pair of the table probably do this is
very conveniently done in Mathematica it
was no problem at all when I tried as it
wasn't immediately worked and of course
to make the performance of the whole
testing better one one should do at some
point an exhaustive search for all
genuine high auto correlations in the
data using a combination of medicine
started doing this first idea would be
to search for all repeating patterns
with another message the two tapes
message that was published in 1988 by a
blitz engage time and then test for our
auto correlations between events using
only these found patterns that actually
do repeat otherwise we have this comm
unit or explosion program and this
alleviates is a bit still we would have
a memory problem so I tried this and
with the same data that we're using like
two gigabytes of memory during the
computation before with the message that
I showed you if you go to this
exhaustive testing you merely need like
a hundred gigabytes of memory end and
this notebook cannot handle it but you
one could do a trick and use some some
bitwise representation in computation of
patterns as you probably know typically
a number is represented in Mathematica
was using 64-bit of things yeah it's
represent with 64 bits and if you could
go down to one bit you need path cost
much less memory and this can be done if
you use the two tapes method
you essentially have it's called like
two tapes because you have the data as a
think of a sheet of paper with holes in
it it also represented kind of the
spatial temporal pattern that better
there so you have time on the x-axis and
then you have some events and if you
have two copies of these of these papers
and slide them against each other at
some offsets you will have some
overlapping holes and these are actually
the repeating patterns that you have in
the data and it's enough for this method
to have them represented as as single
bits so this I'm working on actually
currently and of course it would be very
interesting to apply this method to
other research areas like for example
genomic data financial data or any other
big data for example schizophrenia is a
gene related disease and there are like
no like a few hundred candidate genes
that people think are related to the
appearance of schizophrenia and early
adulthood the one gene that was found
that can explain most of the or that has
the biggest explanatory power for
explaining the onset of schizophrenia
can explain six percent of the cases so
this is not really the way one could go
so one would need to find these high or
decorations beyond pairwise so I'm not
like checking two but taking more at the
same time and having much bigger
explanatory power hopefully in this way
but this means finding these are our
auto correlations yeah this I would
really be interested in to do in the
future so thanks for listening the
algorithms are published in this paper
you can download it you can also
download the the notebook there